So the goal is to define a faster Fibonacci procedure, fast enough
to enable us to compute fibonacci 36. To estimate, at least according
to fibonacci's model, how many rabbits there will be in three years.
And I'm going to give you a little hint for how to
do this. So we're going to want a while loop, and the
loop is going to go up to end, but within the loop you
are going to need to keep track of two things. You are
going to need to keep track of the two previous fibonacci numbers.
And instead of going backwards the recursive definition did, we
started with our base cases. We started with our base cases
with zero and one and then we defined every previous case
by adding the previous two. So to compute this with the
while loop. If we keep track of the previous two in variables
then you can compute the next one by adding those. And
then what you gotta figure out is how to keep
up-to-date the variables, to know what the previous two are
each time you go through the loop. So see if you can figure out
how to define fibonacci yourself. Test it
on some of the smaller numbers before trying
it on fibonacci 36. But if you define it this way, you should be able
to compute fibonacci numbers for much higher
inputs than we could with our recursive definition.